two American teenagers have been
implicated in the murder of an Italian
policeman in Rome elder Finnegan Lee and
Christian Gabriel natal North were named
by police this morning after the officer
was stabbed to death on Friday Seth
Doane joins us from Rome now Seth good
morning good morning this is the prison
where those two 19 year old Americans
are being held they are still awaiting
formal charges but Italy's carbonaria
police forces that they have confessed
and they are being detained were at the
crimes of aggravated murder and
attempted extortion this after a 35 year
old newlywed carbonaria officer named
mario lega was stabbed to death on a
Rome Street early Friday morning the
Carabinieri say their investigation
reveals that shortly before the murder
the two young men stole a backpack from
an Italian man and then threatened him
during a phone call that they would not
return the backpack unless they were
given a hundred euros and a gram of
cocaine the man reported the incident to
Carabinieri who came to the meeting to
try to stop the criminals but a scuffle
unfolded and the cutter Benetti officer
was stabbed to death
law enforcement officials found the two
men at the hotel where they were staying
here in Rome they were ready to leave
Italy early Friday morning they also say
that they found the murder weapon a
knife of considerable size that had been
tucked behind a removable ceiling tile
now Jeff a funeral for that slain cutter
boniato officer will be held on Monday
at the very same church where he was
married just 43 days ago except thank
you my gosh what a horrible right 43
days ago hard to believe the top of the
world